the death of a police officer following
a shootout Thursday is just a slice of
violence near the UNLV campus good
evening I'm Denise Valdez that area near
Flamingo and University Center where
that shootout happened is being called
now a hot spot for Crime that's where we
find Ryan Matthey tonight with nearby
security concerns and what police is
trying to do about it Ryan
we're just
a step from the main UNLV campus and new
data shows that outside of the strip
these neighborhoods surrounding the UNLV
campus take up much of Petey's time and
leave those nearby fearing for their
safety
September 10th a man running from police
during a traffic stop shot an officer
and died when the officer fired back
near the main UNLV campus four days
later a series of stabbings over a week
where police say a man seemingly
targeted homeless women around the same
area and most recently there metro
police officer trong Tai shot and killed
while responding to a domestic dispute
by the man potentially involved in the
dispute we are seeing an increase in
violence Associated against our officers
it's an area Sheriff Joe Lombardo says
Metro's eyes are glued to a growing hot
spot for Crime we're going to ensure
that we put all hands on deck to ensure
that we provide safety in that community
area recent statistics from Metro PD
show 18 homicides there just this year
when in every five metro PD drug
offenses and around 16 percent of its
Society crimes second only to the area
that includes the strip we had some
conversations about being proactive UNLV
police official telling 8 news now
they're considering an increase in
Patrol which may include officers in
plain clothes but with law enforcement
short staffed and struggling to hire
more is it enough for those who pass
through every day you wouldn't come out
here unless you needed to be unless I
needed wheel or bad Syria seems to be
kind of going downhill at the moment and
that maybe the community needs to like
get together and do something about it
now this specific zip code 89119 also
takes top spot for several other crimes
throughout the valley arson burglary
motor vehicle theft just to name a few
reporting live near Flamingo and
University Center Ryan Matthey 8 News
Now